j'en ai plus qu'assez d'essayer d'être
la mère parfaite
oh [ __ ] mais tu as fait qu'internet
est normal c'est carrément par bit
j'ai quelqu'un c'est le pénis depuis que
je suis sur le marché et si tout ce
qu'un clip à circoncire faux culs relais
à mort et courir très loin j'en ai plus
qu'assez d'essayer d'être la mère
parfaite
soyons les maires lundi lors sa branche
ou amis il salue j'appelais pour savoir
si tu voulais faire un ciné avec moi
aujourd'hui pourquoi on a le droit de
faire ça oh [ __ ] tu appliqué à thales
j'étais les cassettes tennis depuis que
je suis sur le marché ici tout ce que
quelqu'un qui pas circoncis course hors
de la chambre en hurlant c'est comme
trouver un flamme devant chez toi faut
hurler à mort et courir très loin